[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara hallweg guten Abend an diesem
zweiten Advent Norbert Lehmann ist auch
dabei für den Sport ein schön guten
abendag von mir schauen wir auf die
nachrichtenthen von
heute Ehrung ohne geehrte weil Iran die
Freiheitskämpferin narges Mohammadi im
Gefängnis festhältmen Kinder den
Friedensnobelpreis
[Applaus]
entgegen Wechselbad für Bahnreisende mit
dem Fahrplanwechsel bekommen sie zwar
mehr Verbindungen müssen aber auch mehr
bezahlen und Bravo Rös im Bob bei den
weltcupprennen in LA plananne holen sich
die deutschen Teams fast alle
Podestplätze seit fast 9 Jahren hat
narges Mohammadi ihre Kinder nicht
gesehen die 51-Jährige Iranerin zahlt
einen hohen Preis für ihren Kampf gegen
die Unterdrückung von Frauen und für
Freiheit dafür bekam sie heute den
Friedensnobelpreis in
Abwesenheit die Aktivistin ist nach
Angaben des Nobelkomitees zu insgesamt
31 Jahren Haft und
154 Peitschenhieben verurteilt bei der
Preisverleihung in Oslo wurde sie von
ihren 17-Jährigen Zwillingen vertreten
Henner Hebestreit und Jörg Brase
berichten schon wieder bleibt der Stuhl
eines Ehrengastes leer wie bei der
letzten Verleihung des
Friedensnobelpreises kann auch die
diesjährige Preisträgerin nages mamadi
nicht nach Oslo kommen die iranische
Menschenrechtlerin ist eingesperrt im
berüchtigten teraner wiin Gefängnis ihre
beiden Kinder nehmen den Preis
stellvertreten für Sie in
Empfang ich lei ihr heute meine Stimme
ebenso wie allen Mädchen und Frauen in
Iran die nicht zum Schweigen gebracht
werden
können seit Jahrzehnten kämpft NES MADI
in Iran für Freiheit und Menschenrechte
und gegen die Unterdrückung von Frauen
durch das Regime das Ostler Komitee
würdigt ausdrücklich auch den hohen
persönlichen Einsatz von dem mm die ihre
Tochter berichten
lässt inmitten der Flamme der Gewalt und
des anhaltenden Despotismus geht es in
unserem Kampf seit Jahren mehr ums
Überleben als um die Verbesserung der
Lebensqualität für ir statsmedien und
Zeitungen sind die Proteste und der
Kampf von Menschen wie nages MADI heute
kein Thema doch viele Menschen im Land
verfolgen durchaus was im fernen Oslo
passiert für viele iranische Frauen ist
nages Mohammadi Symbol des Kampfes für
Frauenrechte und Demokratie für sie ist
der Nobelpreis ein starkes und wichtiges
Zeichen andere dagegen fürchten das
Regime könne nun noch härter gegen seine
Kritiker Vorgehen von offizieller Seite
wird die Verleihung des nobel Preises
heute mit keinem Wort erwähnt der Kampf
von nagis Mohammadi und vielen anderen
zeigt auf den Straßen Wirkung wir lassen
uns nicht mehr vorschreiben ob wir
Kopftuch tragen sollen oder nicht sagen
viele die iranischen Frauen sind
selbstbewusster
geworden bei der Deutschen Bahn gilt
seit heute ein neuer Fahrplan vor allem
im Fernverkehr gibt es mehr Angebote und
schnellere Verbindungen allerdings
erhöht die Bahn die Preise mehr
Verlässlichkeit ist wegen der vielen
Baustellen nicht zu erwarten Hans-jürgen
Piel hat
Details zugstillstand nur weil es
kräftig schneit doch auch ohne Schnee
vor im November gerade mal jeder zweite
Fernzug pünktlich mangelnde
Zuverlässigkeit der DB die trotzdem ihre
Preise im Schnitt um 4,9% erhöht
ausgenommen nur die bahncart 50 und alle
sparpreistickets vielleicht
gerechtfertig aber natürlich nicht
attraktiv wenn man die Menschen noch
dazu bringen will mehr mehr auf die Bahn
umzusteigen und nicht das eigene Auto zu
nehmen das ist halt teuer genug man
kauft dann die Sitzplätze noch extra und
dann noch mehr und dann können Sie gerne
auch mal pünktlich kommen doch es bleibt
dabei gerade normalpreisfahrten werden
spürbar teurer Preisbeispiele konnte die
Bahn nicht nennen die sein je nach
Wochentag und Buchungszeitpunkt zu
unterschiedlich die bankkard 25 aber ist
künftig mit 62 90 3 € teurer als bisher
wir haben mit hohen gestiegenen
Energiepreisen zu kämpfen und das führt
auch dazu dass wir uns zu einer aten
Preissteigerung bei unseren
flexpreistickets entschieden haben dafür
gibt es mehr Züge vor allem zwischen
Berlin und München oder
Nordrein-Westfalen aber auch zwischen
Nürnberg und Leipzig Hamburg und
Magdeburg und von Berlin nach Rostock
die Nachtzüge der Österreichischen
Bundesbahn fahren jetzt auch von Berlin
nach Paris und Brüssel im Inland sollen
neue ICE die dbfotte komfortabler und
pannensicherer machen trotzdem die
höheren Preise Treffen nicht alle
Fahrgäste gleich benachteilig sind
eigentlich fast immer die die
Stammkunden weil es für sie teurer wird
und weil man glaubt dass die Stammkunden
schon bei der Stange bleiben alle Kunden
werden sich auch im neuen Jahr auf
Zugausfälle und Behinderungen einstellen
müssen es beginnt die Generalsanierung
der wichtigsten
Hauptstrecken Außenministerin bärbock
hat Israel zu mehr Schutz und Hilfe für
die Zivilbevölkerung im Gazastreifen
aufgerufen auch der Hunger nähre
weiteren Terrorismus bei Israels
Luftangriffen auf mögliche verste der
islamistischen Hamas sind erneut
Menschen verletzt und getötet worden
sowohl im Süden als auch im Norden des
Gazastreifens in Berlin haben gut 3000
Menschen Gesicht gezeigt gegen Judenhass
der seit dem Nahostkrieg verstärk zu
Tage tritt zur Aktion nie wieder ist
jetzt Deutschland steht auf hatte ein
Bündnis aus zahlreichen
gesellschaftlichen Bereichen aufgerufen
mit dabei prominente wiersänger her
grönemer zeitgleich kamen auch in Berlin
etwa 2500 Menschen zu einer
proalästinensischen Demonstration
Ägypten wäht ab heute einen neuen
Präsidenten doch schon jetzt gilt als
sicher dass es der alte sein wird Abdel
fattach als Sissi der ehemalige
Oberbefehlshaber der Armee hatte 2013
Präsident Mursi von der islamistischen
Muslimbrüderschaft gestürzt
vorausgegangen waren blutige
Massenproteste seither geht als Sissi
mit allerhte gegen Kritiker vor seine
Anhänger loben dagegen dass er dem Land
Sicherheit gebracht habe aus Kairo
goline
atai seine Plakate beherrschen fast jede
Straße im Land Feldmarschall abdelattah
Assisi der sich durch eine umstrittene
Verfassungsänderung eine dritte Amtszeit
ermöglicht hat ccis Popularität hatte
zuletzt empfindlich gelitten seitdem die
Landeswährung kollabierte und die
Inflation fast 40% erreichte
schon vor dieser Krise galten fast zwei
Drittel der Ägypter als
arm das ist zutiefst ungerecht dieses
Leben das wir leben müssen die Preise
für Fleisch und
alles wir leben in der Hölle alles ist
teuer Präsident S hat viel erreicht aber
er muss doch mit uns
[Musik]
fühlen der gesunkene Lebensstandard sei
auch seiner Bauwut geschuldet sagen
Experten für seine neue Hauptstadt neue
Straßen und Brücken rief sie sie jüngst
zum Verzicht
auf wenn der Preis von Fortschritt und
Entwicklung Hunger und Entbehrung sein
sollte dann lasst die Ägypter weder
essen noch
trinken den einzigen echten Konkurrenten
ließ s Regime nicht weit kommen der
linksgerichtete Oppositionelle ahm tanti
wurde an der Kandidatur behindert und
ist nun
angeklt der Wahlgewinner steht fest aber
ob dieser siegäsident stärken wird ist
unklar für eine erfolgreiche nächste
Amtszeit müsste er die tiefste
Wirtschafts und Finanzkrise in der
Geschichte Ägyptens bewältigen und den
Einfluss den das Militär auf die
Wirtschaft hat
begrenzen um die Wahlbeteiligung zu
erhöhen soll das Regime Druck ausüben
auf Lehrer und Angestellte oder mit
Geldgeschenken die Stimmabgabe belohnen
das Ergebnis wird in einer Woche
verkündet die deutsche Schauspielerin
Sandra Hüller hat in Berlin den
Europäischen Filmpreis als beste
Darstellerin gewonnen sie bekommt die
Auszeichnung für ihre Rolle im
Justizthriller Anatomie eines falls der
auch in der Kategorie Bester Film
prämiert
wurde und jetzt zum deutschen Bobteam
auch preiswürdig das war beim Weltcup in
LA Plan schwer zu toppen allerdings fünf
von sechs Podestplätzen erst legten die
Frauen im Zweierbob vor Laura Nolte
siegte vor Teamkollegin Kim kaliki ja
und dann räumten die Männer im Viererbob
alles ab allen voran Rekordweltmeister
Francesco
Friedrich groß Erleichterung bei Bob
Rekord weleltmeister Francesco Friedrich
nach seinem ersten Saisonsieg beim
Weltcup in LA Planie war vor allem der
startgrundlage des Erfolges hier war er
der Konkurrenz zum Längen voraus im
maiskanal seine vatn wie gewohnt es ist
die wieder Gutmachung für den verpatzten
Saisonstart in China und Platz 3 im
Zweier Bob gestern am Ende steht der 76
weltcuperfolg von friedich den deutschen
dreifeg perfekt macht Johannes Lochner
der zweiter wird vor dem Jungen Adam
Amur auch bei den Frauen gibt es einen
deutschen Erfolg Olympiasiegerin Laura
Note holt sich den Sieg im Zweierbob das
vor Kim kaliki für Bundestrainer ren
Spieß ein fast perfekter
Renntag und Karl Geiger hat auch das
zweite springen beim halmweltcup in
klingental gewonnen der 30jährige siegte
vor dem Schweizer Gregor des schwanden
und seinem DSV Teamkollegen Andreas
Wellinger für Geiger war es der 15
Weltcup Erfolg seiner
Karriere im ersten Sonntag Spiel der
Fußball Bundesliga trennten sich
Stuttgart und Leverkusen ein zu ein
Bayer bleibt Tabellenführer der VfB drit
alle Höhepunkte des 14 Spieltags ab
Mitternacht bei zdfheute.de und in der
ZDF heute
App und im Topspiel der Frauen hat
Frankfurt gegen Hoffenheim gewonnen die
TSG ging in der vierten Spielminute
durch Julia hickelsberger früh in
Führung später aber dominierte die
Eintracht hier shekira Martinez zum 3:1
Endstand in der 90 Minute Frankfurt
jetzt Dritter und Hoffenheim
vier das war's vom Sport am Sonntag
danke schön die neue Woche startet mild
und nass nördlich des Mains regnet es
verbreitet auch an den Alpen gibt es zum
Teil ergiebigen Regen dazwischen sind
Schauer selten bei einem starken
Westwind werden 6 bis 14° erreicht Anne
gellineck begrüßt sie um : Uhr im heute
journal wir sagen danke und tschüss
wünschen Ihnen einen guten Start in die
neue Woche und blicken jetzt gespannt
nach Berlin zu shakuntala Vany